hey youtubers is Charlie and a bunch of
you guys requested that I do a video for
the Batman vs Superman trail and they
played at Comic Con so that's what this
video is gonna be and I know a lot of
you are super excited about the Deadpool
clip that played and Avengers usually
gets like the top billing
but if you look at just overall mentions
on social media from the weekend Batman
vs Superman was actually the winner and
they didn't even play a trailer it was
really just a short clip in case you
just finding me because of this or all
the Comic Con craziness I do Marvel and
DC videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything so the clip
looked like it was right out of a Frank
Miller panel it was Batman and Gotham on
a rooftop it's raining really hard and
he draws the cover off the bat-signal
lightning strikes and sue Rand is just
there he just appears out of thin air
with glowing red eyes then it cuts to
Batman who's wearing a heavy armor suit
just like you see in Dark Knight Returns
in the comic with the glowing white eyes
they don't speak they had this image of
gal gadot off to the side the high-res
one that they released officially while
the panel is going on she wasn't in
Gotham for that scene she wasn't on that
rooftop with them it was basically like
they had the clip of Batman and Superman
on one side of the screen and the gal
gadot image on the other side of the
screen it was a little weird in Hall H
if you've never been it's got these
giant walls on each side so Studios can
roll out extra viewing screens they kind
of wrap around the audience it's just so
everyone can see better but they always
have like these giant rows of panels
hanging from the ceilings everyone kind
of knew something weird was going on
whenever they rolled out all these extra
screens though to fill up the walls and
just to be clear there wasn't a Batman
vs Superman panel per se it was like a
90-minute Warner Brothers panel during
which they talked about several movies
Batman vs Superman being just the first
one if you didn't see the panel footage
that I posted it was super short it was
only a couple minutes long Zack Snyder
came out intro the clip and then rolled
out the holy trinity the funny thing is
is that he told the organizers on stage
not to give them mics like he didn't
want Ben Affleck Henry Cavill or gal
gadot to speak I actually laughed a
little bit it's not that he had any
super-secret motivation for doing that
he probably just thought that they'd be
more effective not speaking they're
still right in the middle of filming so
they actually had to stop production to
fly the actors in and then fly them
right back right away the production
delays are really expensive because they
still have to
the crew whenever they're not shooting
so bringing those three actors to
comic-con for about two minutes of that
chris hardwick selfie probably cost a
half a million dollars most expensive
chris hardwick selfie ever one of the
biggest comment threads that I saw on
the video I posted was that Ben
Affleck's Batman is taller than Henry
Cavill or Ben Affleck in real life is
taller than Henry Cavill that is I guess
you guys felt like Superman should be
taller but that's just the actors most
actors in general are pretty short but
leading men like a list hundred and
fifty million dollar movie leading men
tend to be over six feet tall minimum
like six feet is the minimum Ben Affleck
is like six four and Henry Cavill is
only six one but in the movie they're
probably gonna be about the same height
that's not counting the extra inches
that Ben Affleck gets from the ears on
his cowl but they did shorten them to
look more like the Frank Miller versions
so for those that are going crazy about
little details like this whenever
they're like on screen together in frame
together they're probably gonna be I to
I just to increase the dramatic tension
they don't want one to be bigger than
the other I've already talked about the
rumored story arc of their relationship
that is but since a lot of you guys
might be new to my channel in the last
couple of weeks I'll talk about it again
real quick so the rumor is that Batman
is pissed at Superman for being like a
bull in the china shop the china shop
being the earth so Superman is treated
by Batman and the other superheroes of
the world as an alien the movies
subtitle is dawn of Justice as in dawn
of Justice League so presumably during
the course of the events Superman will
win Batman's trust but not at first
so that doesn't address anything about
gal gadot's Wonder Woman character or
her arc as well as cyborg or the Aquaman
rumor which is like even a bigger rumor
I know Jason Momoa was rumored for the
Aquaman role but nothing's been
confirmed it all ties in with the idea
that Superman's battle with Zod in the
first movie destroyed half the planet
mostly damage done by those world
engines so the Earth's heroes call on
him to answer for what he's done or what
his people have done to the earth that
could be what that bad signal scene was
about the comic-con teaser like the
moment that Batman calls Superman out it
would definitely explain why in the
pictures they show to both of them they
look super angry at each other so let's
talk about some of the other characters
real quick
cyborg huge character from the comic
books we really don't know much about
what he's doing in the movie or what his
ties are to the other heroes or the
aside from lex luthor there are four
rumored villains lexcorp's supposed to
be a big tech company like Facebook or
Google but since we don't know if
they're a software giant or a hardware
giant I can't really tie cyborg to them
cyborgs usually tied to STAR Labs in the
comics and during the first Man of Steel
movie they did have a STAR Labs Easter
Egg during the military base scenes the
logo was just playing on screens in the
background so I'm guessing as the
nations and the peoples of the earth
gathered their heroes to go confront
Superman the military just throats
cyborg in the ring as like their hat
like they throw their hat in the ring
the other rumored villains are Morgan
edge who is like the publicity person
for Lex Corp he'll be like a media mogul
like Rupert Murdoch before the new 52
reboot he was also the leader of
inter-gang
then there's Victor Zsasz who's like a
freaky serial killer that just tattoos
himself every time he kills someone
then there's David Kane who's another
mercenary affiliated with the League of
Assassins I know we've been visiting
that group a lot on arrow and then
there's Amanda Waller who's also been
featured a lot on arrow recently but
those are just rumors they haven't
confirmed any of the other rogues
gallery of villains that the movies
gonna use and a lot of people were
wondering about metallo supposedly
there's not gonna be any metallo but
that's also a rumor too so take it with
a grain of salt just to tie it back to
arrow I know a lot of people have been
talking about TVs and movies stuff but
if you've seen Cynthia at I Robinson on
arrow she's actually been doing a great
job as Amanda Waller on that show she's
the head of Argus and even though Bruce
Wayne and all the other characters exist
in that universe she's just never made
mention of them one of the really cool
thing from Comic Con was that Jeff
John's like full-on addressed the TV
movie universe crossover stuff he
basically said that TV is gonna be TV
movies are gonna be movie I know that's
gonna be disappointing for some people
but I don't think it's gonna be awful
Stephen Amell said this really cool
thing though on television because they
have all these amazing characters coming
this fall you basically going to be
getting that Justice League every single
week and I definitely agree that it's
gonna be an awesome thing I don't mind
treating the movies and the TV shows as
totally alternate universes it doesn't
mean it's always gonna be that way it's
just gonna be like that for the
foreseeable future
at least until there's a big regime
change in the film division at Warner
Brothers a long time ago Stephen Amell
actually said this funny thing someone
asked them if you know Bruce Wayne ever
came on arrow who would you want to play
him he said oh of course Robbie Amell
cut to today
he's actually playing firestorm on the
flash and will cross over with arrow
it's great how meta some of these TV
shows are starting to get so in a lot of
you guys may have already seen the
comic-con clip it did leak it was super
short but they took it down so in case
you haven't don't worry but I don't
think that they're gonna be making that
public whenever they do release a teaser
trailer it'll be something that's
totally different it'll look way more
polished I will keep doing bonus videos
for the movie whenever new things happen
but most of my DC videos tend to be TV
videos there's actually gonna be six new
DC TV shows this fall which is crazy
there's arrow season 3 of course which
is returning then there's five new ones
including the flash Gotham Constantine
izombie I'm actually not gonna be doing
videos for that one and then there's
preacher preacher is actually gonna be
an AMC show that won't premiere till
2015 Gotham is Fox Constantine is NBC
and all the others of course are CW
obviously if you guys have been watching
my arrow videos or my flash videos you
know that arrow and flash are gonna do a
ton of crossovers there's not a lot of
promise for a Gotham crossover they
haven't completely ruled it out but the
showrunner for Gotham said that
supposedly that show takes place in an
alternate universe so I'm not planning
on it I know that I still owe you guys
reviews of Gotham and Constantine from
this past weekend but since I'm behind
and most of you have not seen those
shows I might just wait till they
actually premiere to do review videos
but I'll make you guys a deal if you
really want me to do reviews for
Constantine and Gotham those first
episodes just let me know in the
comments obviously and click the like
button if this video gets like 2000
likes before Friday or Saturday I'll
totally do reviews for those right now
that you can click here to watch my
review of episode 1 of the flash and you
can click here to watch the Batman vs
Superman panel footage thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you